Good morning everybody today.
I am going to,
well actually let me step back for a second.
I have been mentioning to you in the last several weeks,
I've been mentioning to you more than once,
the fact that we are,
uh,
we have been beginning to see what I've described as the baroque element in
Roman architecture,
the baroque element in Roman architecture.
And I want to concentrate on that particular aspect of Roman architecture today,
which is why I called the lecture Baroque extravaganzas.
I want to make that the beginning at the outset.
I want to make a few points.
I want to highlight what I see as the three major features of a baroque
architecture in the Roman period.
The first of these is that those buildings that are baroque or at least the
architects and patrons who designed buildings that we think of today as Baroque
or we might define as baroque buildings.
Uh,
they,
they use the traditional vocabulary of architecture.
They use the traditional vocabulary of architecture.
And by what,
by that I mean,
uh,
the traditional vocabulary of Greek and a trust in architecture for the most
part.
I'm speaking now of columns.
I'm speaking of pediments and I'm also speaking of lintels and in tablatures and
the like,
they use all of that traditional vocabulary,
but they use it in a very different way.
That's number one.
Number two is that Baroque Roman,
Roman,
ancient Roman Baroque buildings,
uh,
tend to be decorated in a very ornate fashion,
almost two or nature.
In fact,
we'll see that these buildings are covered with decoration.
So much so that they seem to dematerialize,
uh,
some of the architectural elements,
including those ones that make up that traditional vocabulary of architecture.
The third,
uh,
and in some respects the most important is the fact that they use these
traditional elements of architecture to,
they use them in a way to Enlive in the surface to create motion,
to create a sense of undulation I and that in and out the,
in and out a projection and recession that I mentioned on a few occasions.
We see that interjected into these works of architecture of the so called
Baroque style.
So keep those three,
those three characteristics in mind as we look at a host of buildings today.
I also want to mention that we'll focus primarily today on the eastern part of
the empire where we see a particularly large number of these baroque buildings
in large part because there was a strong tradition in that part of the world for
using that traditional vocabulary of architecture because of the very strong
impact of Greece and Greek architecture and have the very,
uh,
have access to,
um,
to,
uh,
high quality marble from that part of the world,
which of course is needed for columns and the light.
So we'll focus on the eastern part of the empire.
I also want to,
um,
want to make the point that one,
when one thinks about baroque architecture in general,
one thing's not a Roman antiquity,
but rather of the 17th century in Italy,
one thinks in particular have to master architects to great architectural giants
who were on the world stage at that particular time.
And that is,
uh,
Vr Bernini John Lorenzo Bernini and also a Francesco Borromini Francesco
Borromini Bernini and Borromini,
uh,
who were themselves rivals architectural rivals,
put up buildings in fact that are often in dialog with one another.
I think in particular of the Piazza Navona where we have Bernini's four Rivers
Fountain and borrow Minis Church on Sunday on gays,
they're in a Gonyet,
uh,
and the way in which they were set up to speak to one another.
I don't know if any of you,
I'm sure many of you know the four Rivers Fountain where one of the rivers has
his hand up like this to protect himself a friend.
The implication is he needs to protect himself.
He's facing Bernie's building.
Uh,
uh,
he's,
he's facing,
he,
excuse me,
he's facing Borromini his church and he needs to protect himself.
That is Bernini's river needs to protect himself from Bara mini's church.
The implication being that if he doesn't,
if he needs to hold up his hand because Borromini his church is going to
collapse because it's so poorly executed.
So there's very interesting dialogue between the two men.
And again,
we think of that primarily when we think of Baroque.
And just a couple of examples I show you here and I'll show you a number of them
in the course of the lecture today,
especially Bar Munies work.
Uh,
but I wanted to focus right at the moment on Saint Peter's on Pa Dro.
you see it here,
the Saint Peters as designed,
the Dome is designed as we've discussed before by Michelangelo.
Uh,
the facade designed by Carlos Moderno,
also 17th century architect,
but most interesting are the embracing oval arms,
uh,
Bernini's colonnade.
And you can see that so well in the view on the upper left,
the embracing arms of that colonnade and all the motion and the in and out
movement that we find both on the facade,
uh,
and in the embracing arms is characteristic of 17th century baroque
architecture.
But I want to maintain today as I've maintained in the course of the semester,
that the Romans,
there wasn't anything that the Romans didn't do first,
uh,
and that it is Roman Baroque architecture as we're going to it today.
Or that had a huge impact on architects like Borromini and Bernini.
And I remind you of a couple of instances of that.
Think back,
I mean this,
the whole idea of using hemi cycles,
curves and architecture,
uh,
is begun by the Romans of course in such buildings as the,
sanctuary of 14 for two and a premed Jania Palestrina where you see one of the
Hemi cycles up there.
Uh,
and you'll remember that from our discussion of the paper topics that Injera
Asa,
uh,
there was an Oval Piatsa or oval forum,
well before,
uh,
the oval colonnade of Bernini.
So again,
what I'm going to try to demonstrate today is how important this baroque
architecture in Roman antiquity is not only in its own right,
but also as a model and a spur to the architects of the 17th century in Italy.
We have touched upon the,
uh,
the beginnings of Roman Baroque architecture incipient,
we might call it incipient Roman Baroque architecture in a few instances.
And I just want to remind you of those today.
I think back to second style Roman wall painting,
I remind you of the room of the masks and the house of Augustus,
uh,
where you see,
this theatrical facade done in paint that represents columns,
uh,
with a,
with projecting and projecting elements or lentils on either side.
And then a kind of a pediment above.
We saw our first explorations of this kind of thing in painting already in 60 to
50 BC and then in this case in the 30s to 20 BC.
And we maintained at that point that there was probably a direct relationship
between three theatrical architecture and these kinds of paintings,
but we don't have much in the way of preserved,
uh,
built architecture at that time that partakes of some of these characteristics.
But we think it's possible that there may have been,
as I mentioned then some wooden,
some uh,
some,
uh,
skein.
I frons with this,
these kinds of effects done in wood that no longer survive today.
You'll remember also a,
that we looked at the form transitory IOM in Rome of the forum,
first of demission and then completed by nerve.
And I show you a detail of that again,
and this is when we really begin to see in built architecture,
uh,
this,
this move toward what we're defining today as the baroque enrollment
architecture.
Uh,
and you can see that what we have here are the traditional,
the traditional vocabulary of architecture columns in this case,
Corinthian columns with projecting and tablatures on top,
uh,
creating a system of a receiving and progressing bays across this across the
surface,
which created a kind of undulating movement across the sides of the forum.
Uh,
and then you'll remember also if you look at the freeze that the freeze
continues,
uh,
along the sides of the columns columns as well.
And then in the,
uh,
a relief of Minerva up on top,
it's not quite,
I wouldn't call it overly ornate quite yet.
Uh,
but it is ordinate.
And you'll remember that during the Flavian period,
for example,
there was a lot of interest in ornate decoration.
So we're beginning to see some ex exploration of this kind of thing.
And then it comes full blown.
In the early third century.
Aad,
the CEP disodium,
the facade that was designed for Septa,
me a severity for the pallet to add to the Palatine palace that had been built
by demission,
this incredible facade a that is more show than anything else.
We think it may also have served as a fountain,
as I mentioned,
very much looking like a theater set with two with three very large niches,
uh,
columns on the curve.
Uh,
and then a series of columns placed in three tiers with wings on either side.
And we have a sense that this too was quite decorative.
So all of those elements,
the use of the traditional language of architecture,
columns,
lintels and so on,
uh,
an interest in a very decorative surface.
And then above all this,
uh,
this interjection of motion,
into the structure projecting bay receiving bay,
projecting day,
receiving bay,
all using the traditional language of architecture,
the traditional vocabulary of architecture,
namely columns and the like.
Then I also showed you the tomb,
the second century tomb of the titanic.
He under the Vatican in Rome and we looked at this accident metric view and ward
Perkins showing the brick faced a brick face,
concrete facade with express,
with exposed the exposed brick that was popular at that time.
But we focused in on the interior of the structure where I mentioned the through
architect tonic means the architects had,
had um,
had had a embellished this surface and created a interesting motion in that
surface.
And you see here this same idea of split as we see in the paintings of the
second style triangular pediment has been split apart to reveal another
triangular pediment inside a with a niche as you can see and the rest of the
wall embellished with columns.
So once again,
the sense of in and out movement across the sides of that wall and walls.
And here you see a view of it as it looks today,
the,
the columns and so on are no longer there.
But you can reconstruct them in your mind's eye underneath these capitals and
get a very good sense of this articulation,
what we might call a kind of baroque articulation of the walls.
I mentioned already that most of our best examples of a Roman ancient Roman
Baroque architecture can be found in the eastern part of the empire.
And I'd like to concentrate on those today,
although we'll look,
we won't look at those exclusively.
I do have a couple of examples from the West as well.
I'm going to actually start in the west,
uh,
at a place called Santa Maria Cappola Vater Ray and I show it to you on the map
here.
It is close to all the sites in Campania that we'd been talking about this
semester.
You see on pay and Herculaneum and a plant is and via for example,
and Ben Event and over here Naples.
And you can see the proximity of Santa Maria Cup or bay tray to all of those
that we've already covered.
A and in Santa Maria,
capo of Hra has been found an extremely WellPreserved Roman tomb.
And you see it here in the center of the screen,
a Roman tomb that dates to the late first century,
a d it is very clear that it is made of concrete construction,
uh,
and that it is faced with opus.
And Keratin work,
which you can see here very clearly,
but you can also see that some brick has been used,
uh,
around the,
niches,
uh,
and as a molding both for these cylinders and for the throw laws above.
This is confused scholars.
They don't know when to date this.
Also because of these so called burrow characteristics where you see this
undulating facade with the use of,
well,
they're not really,
columns are more like cylinders and in that sense,
similar to the cylinders that we saw in the tomb of the baker,
these cylinders with the undulating,
the sod,
the use of architectural elements,
the interest in deck declaration,
uh,
and,
the cylinders have have confused fellers as I said,
and they have been betwixt in between when to date this thing.
Uh,
and some have said that it dates at the time of the,
uh,
of such buildings as the sanctuary of for two and a Prima Janie at Palestrina
because of the opposite and carry them.
Others have said because of the use of brick here,
uh,
which we actually think in this case was stuccoed over,
that it might be later,
second century had.
Uh,
but I think,
but this is actually more like the tile brick that we saw in Pompei,
uh,
rather than the kind of brick that we see in Ostia.
So I favor the first century date for essentially for a century,
a d date,
but we have to think it is very proficient of what is to come experimenting as
did some of those other buildings that I just showed you the forum transitory
them,
for example,
with the sort of thing that is going to become particularly popular in the
second and third centuries.
A D.
Now I juxtapose this to,
and by the way,
this tomb,
the nickname of this to him as you can see from your monument list is La
[inaudible] Nokia lock a Nokia means the distaff and a distaff is used in
spinning and weaving.
Uh,
so a spinning thread primarily.
So I,
and it looks like an ancient distaff.
Uh,
so some,
some soaks.
That's when,
that's how it got its nickname.
Laca Nokia.
Whether that means that that was intended by the designers and that this was a
tomb of a perhaps a woman,
uh,
who was,
you know,
or,
or a man working in a factory who,
um,
who spun thread.
I think that's very far fetched.
I think it's highly unlikely,
but I just throw it out there.
Uh,
but uh,
that is what its nickname is.
But you can see by the juxtaposition of it with the tomb of the baker on the
right and with the monument of the Julie and Savanah me in the south of France,
which we haven't looked up at,
which we will look at a,
in a lecture next week on a Roman architecture in,
in the south of France primarily.
Uh,
you will see that it makes a reference to both of these,
both of these earlier.
This is,
as you know,
Augusta,
and the one on the left is from the late time of Julius Caesar.
And you can see that it takes elements,
I'm not saying it looked at these in particular,
but just that these kinds of elements were already,
uh,
in,
in the air,
uh,
when this building was built in the light for a century and the great cylinders
of the tumor of Rissa keys,
but it is more similar actually to this one because the jewelry he monument and
also lock a Nokia are examples of what we call the tower tomb type.
The tower tomb type is taller than it is wide.
It has a series of stories in this case,
a plane story.
I then a central story with the cylinders and then the full loss at the top.
And we see the same sort of thing.
And the Juilliard Monument stepped base,
uh,
softball here with sculptural decoration,
a quadro fronds,
and then a thorough loss at the very apex.
But it's interesting to see the differences between the two,
uh,
because what we see in this monument,
again,
is much more what we would call a baroque in the sense that we have the
undulating facade.
We have the use of what looked like in,
in a general way,
the originally traditional vocabulary of architecture with these cylinders,
with the niches,
with the pediments.
But look at the way the thought of loss is treated.
When you look at the thought of loss in the Julie Monument,
you see that it really does look like a shrine and it has statues inside like a
shrine would,
uh,
this one has blind windows,
as you can see,
you can't see into it.
There's nothing inside.
So they're treating the thaw loss more as a decorative motif,
a than they are treating it as something that can have,
that has the purpose of holding a,
some,
some either religious items or statues or honorific statues as it does in this
particular case.
Another view of Lacan Nokia,
a detail,
which I think shows you what I mean about a motion being,
uh,
being introduced into monuments like this.
This,
in this case,
we are dealing with concrete and that is somewhat different.
The use of concrete to create undulation,
then the use of,
uh,
of the traditional vocabulary of architecture.
But here we see a combination,
the concrete wall faced with the opposite and care to him,
the great cylinders on the edge.
Uh,
and then the,
uh,
Idig Ula here with the pediment and the niche below.
And you can also see very well the cylinders that are located between the blind
windows as well as this combination of opus and care to him work.
And also,
uh,
the tile brick that is used to,
represent the moldings and the like.
I want to compare,
uh,
the central zone of Lacan oh Kia with a 17th century baroque building in Rome.
This is Francesco Borromini Sundt Evoh in Rome,
uh,
taken from an angle that accentuates the curvature of the facade and the
contrast between the con cavity of that curvature and the convexity of the
outside of the dome that you see up above the same sort of thing here.
So once again,
architects of the 17th century very much inspired by these.
Uh,
the,
these kinds of motifs that survived from a Roman antiquity on the left hand side
of the screen,
you'll all remember this,
this is the elliptical fountain from the Palace of Demission on the Palatine
Hill that was located,
that he could see through his window out of the trickling IOM when he dined.
And no,
remember here also in this case made out of concrete construction designed by
areas you see the elliptical wall and the convexity of that elliptical wall,
the central element also convex.
Uh,
but with these interesting a con cavities,
scallops,
uh,
that [inaudible] has created through concrete,
faced with brick around the structure.
So in that case,
you know,
all I'm trying to do here is show you that you can create similar effects either
in concrete or through columnar architecture.
But what separates concrete con,
the revolutionary concrete architecture as we've discussed it today,
and Baroque architecture as I'm going to define it this morning,
uh,
is that in Baroque architecture,
they're relying on the traditional vote,
not on concrete,
but on the traditional vocabulary of architecture.
Namely of course,
columns pediments and the like to create their effects.
And in a place where it all comes together,
you'll recall is at Hadrian's villa at Tivoli.
We're looking here at the Piatsa,
Doro plan of the Piatsa,
Doro,
the octagonal vestibule,
the great open rectangular space that you can see here.
And then the hour law or the audience hall on the far right.
And you'll remember the Allah had these wonderful undulating walls.
But what separated the outflow from other undulating walls that we had seen
earlier is that it was not done with concrete,
uh,
but was done with columns.
You'll remember the columns were placed in such a way that they followed the
curved shape,
uh,
and then they supported a concrete dome.
So this wonderful combination of the use of traditional language of architecture
along and undulating form.
Uh,
and then with the concrete at the top so we can see already in the Adriatic
period,
further exploration of this kind of thing.
I also want to show you a very interesting painting,
painted a room.
And this is in the house of the labyrinth at palm pay.
It's early in date,
dates to 50 BC,
but it's an extraordinary room.
It's the atrium of the house.
And we talked about several different kinds of atria.
We talked about the atrium that had a no columns at all.
Uh,
and we talked about the tech style atrium,
which had four columns around the central basin.
What you see here are a host of columns surrounding that central base.
And then when you have a number of columns like this,
more than four a,
we call it a,
um,
a,
a Corinthian atrium,
a Corinthian atrium with lots of columns.
And what you can see the artist and patron have done here is to orchestrate the
relationship of those real columns with the fictive architecture that is painted
on the wall and to play them up in such a way that is,
you're standing in the room,
you are,
you are looking through the real columns,
uh,
to see this view that lies behind of Othello loss,
which you can view through the broken triangular pediments.
I show it to you for a couple of reasons.
One,
just to remind you that we saw this kind of thing in painting very early on.
This is again,
50 BC in the republic steel.
As we,
as we see the architects taking the traditional vocabulary of architecture and
playing with it,
breaking it up,
opening it,
uh,
and revealing something that lies behind,
in this case,
the throw loss.
But look also at the way in which the throw loss looks like it's in the
distance.
You get the sense that you are looking through an opening in the wall,
a window in which you can see that though loss.
It seems to lie behind the broken triangular pediment.
The pediment has been broken open to allow you to see a vista that lies behind.
And you get the sense as you look at this painting,
that the throw loss is surrounded by a peristyle and that there's also some
greenery.
And so,
so on out there.
And then to accentuate this idea of the view through the wall,
they have then added the columns here so that you're looking through the car,
through real columns,
to fictive columns to broken triangular pediment to the thought of loss,
uh,
that lies behind.
You'll see the relevance of this.
When we look at some additional monuments.
I want to move.
I want to now go east,
uh,
to look at some of the most spectacular examples that survive,
what we are calling a baroque architecture in Roman antiquity today.
And I want to begin in a site that is,
that is,
that is in modern Jordan.
I'm showing you a map of the eastern Roman empire.
Uh,
and we see the site in question Piedra or some say Petra.
You can call it either one pietra or Petra.
You see Pietra over here,
uh,
which is in,
Jordan today.
Uh,
and you can see its relationship to the Red Sea,
to Egypt,
to Alexandria,
uh,
to uh,
Yudaya modern Israel,
uh,
and to some of these other sites.
One,
in fact,
a couple of others that we'll look at Baalbek today.
And the site of Jerica,
which is where that Oval Piatsa or forum comes from.
Here's another map of Peatra just to show you where it is located today within
Jordan,
its relationship to Amman and to the ancient side of Gera sets.
You can see up at the bottom,
a fairly close to the Israeli border as you can see,
as well as to Alcapa down below.
Just to get you in the mood for Peatra.
Uh,
we are walking here,
there are incredible cliffs,
uh,
here as well as desert credible cliffs.
And we're walking here through what is known as the Sikh in Petra.
And I want to mention that this is one of those interesting provinces where,
uh,
in order to understand the architecture that was built during the Roman period,
you have to have a sense of the local customs of what happened to you before the
buildings that were built prior to the Roman period.
And we know that the so called Nabateans,
n a,
B,
a t nabet and a B a,
t,
a,
e a,
n,
s,
Nabataeans,
uh,
live to your inhabited this part of the world before the Romans got there.
And we know that the Nabataeans built architecture and that they build
architecture primarily out of the stone of the cliffs,
uh,
and also out of mud.
Uh,
and one can imagine the kinds of things that you see here.
The Rock cut tombs already begun during the NAB T in period.
And it's interesting if you look very closely at some of the detailed decoration
here.
Uh,
you can see something that any of you who wrote your paper on the temple of bell
at Pal Myra,
remember the sort of stepped,
uh,
the step of motif decoration.
We see the same sort of thing here,
but just important for you to know that the Nabataeans were building with stone
and with,
uh,
with mud before the Roman period.
And so when the Romans came in and began to build their own architecture,
obviously the impact of what had been built there earlier had,
uh,
made an impression on them.
They too decided to build their tombs out of the living rock of Petra.
And they are among the most spectacular and unusual tombs that survived from the
Roman period.
And I want to show two of them to you today.
The so called day or d I r and the so called [inaudible],
We will look at both of them with the day year first.
And if you look at the day year and the way that in which it has been created,
by carving it out of the living rock,
you should not only be impressed,
uh,
but you should say to yourself,
wow,
this is Roman facade is at its greatest at its most obvious as well.
This is really Roman facade ism because all there is is the facade.
There's nothing else.
The tomb itself is located inside the rock.
The tomb chambers are inside the rock.
They didn't do anything to them except hollow them out,
nothing much else there.
They've concentrated all of their efforts on the facade,
which seems to grow out of the rock almost as if by nature.
And if you look at,
uh,
at,
at this tomb,
the day year,
you should also be struck immediately by the way in which,
uh,
what the Romans have created here is a version and built architecture of what we
saw already in 60 to 50 BC in second style Roman wall painting.
It is exactly the same kind of thing.
This idea of breaking a triangular pediment open to reveal a full loss,
uh,
that lies inside,
in,
in this case.
On a second story,
we see all of the elements that I've already mentioned or most of the other
elements that I've already mentioned.
We see here in this facade the use of the traditional vocabulary of
architecture,
the columns,
uh,
the tablature above,
and we and pediments and so on down here,
triangular pediments down here.
We see all of those but used in a way that the Greeks would never have done.
Uh,
and we see we see less than this one.
I'll show you better examples of this interest in over ornamentation.
There is ornamentation here,
but it's actually fairly simple.
So this one doesn't partake of that as much as other others that I can show you,
uh,
but it,
but it does definitely by using the traditional vocabulary of architecture,
the surface is enlivened by creating elements that project look at these columns
on either side with their projecting and tablatures standing alone or more
pilasters and columns.
In this case,
standing alone,
projecting or receiving bay,
a projecting bay or receiving bay,
a Projecting Bay,
uh,
instilling motion across this surface by means of the traditional vocabulary of
architecture.
Again in this case on two levels.
Here's another view of the facade of the day year on the lefthand side of the
screen and you can see the material used is obviously the rock itself.
This has been literally carved out of the living rock so that it's obviously the
same stone and the same color as the rock.
That's still a,
that still serves as its backdrop.
And then over here the house of the labyrinth.
Again just to show you again the close,
the close resemblance of this sort of thing in the mid second century.
Aidy in what is now Jordan,
uh,
two second style Roman wall painting.
And I show you again the throw laws within the broken triangular pediment but
the main difference between the two and here is where we do get into this whole
concept of decoration and even over decoration.
The main difference between the two is when you're standing again in the house
of the labyrinth,
looking through the actual columns toward the painting and you see that the,
the triangular pediment has been broken to reveal the laws.
As I mentioned before,
you still have a sense of space and you still have a sense of reality.
Even though the pediment has been broken,
you seem to be,
you are looking at Athol loss and you're meant to think that that throw laws
lies inside a peristyle corridor or a garden that is outside the house that
you're seeing through a window.
So you read the full laws,
or at least I read the thought of loss as further back than the broken
triangular pediment that is entirely different here.
Yes,
there's a thought loss.
there's a broken triangular pediment but the throw loss has been turned into a
decorative motif among many.
Uh,
it is a thorough loss,
yes,
but it doesn't look like a working throw law,
so to speak.
You can see that it has a niche in the center of it.
Just like the other bays have niches that probably held a statue,
but you don't have a sense that there is any space in there.
Uh,
it is,
it is a decoration on the surface,
on the facade of this structure,
just like all the other decorations.
And that is a major difference between the way in which the [inaudible] is used
in the day year and the throw loss is used in typical second style Roman wall
painting.
You may also have noticed some of the decoration and I'm going to show you some
details now so that we can look at those together.
Here you get a very good sense of the color of the stone,
of the rocks of Peatra.
Uh,
but you also see here at Capitol that is unlike any capital that we have seen
before.
And this is where we see the influence of the Nabataeans.
The Nabataeans were building buildings that had capitals that look like this
sort of interesting undulating capitols,
but very plain plain with a,
with a,
a con concave side,
uh,
and then a kind of Knob in the center.
As you can see here,
these are navety and capitals and in this mid second century Aidy tomb,
you can see that they are looking,
they're clearly looking at models from Rome.
Uh,
they are clearly looking at the kinds of paintings that I have already,
uh,
reminded you of,
but at the same time or,
or let's say drawings made from those paintings that are circulated or the
architects may have access to,
but they are combined with local elements.
In this case,
the Nabataeans capitals.
And then if you look at this detail over here,
you will see that they've used a kind of triglyceride and Mehta piece system
with the panels.
And then the triple strided bands that we saw was characteristic of Greek doric
architecture that's used here.
But look at what's in the metal piece.
We don't see anything like this in Greek or Roman architecture or the metaphors.
In fact,
in Greek architecture usually filled with figural scenes,
figural panels.
But here we see these large discs and a disc and each one of these,
uh,
of these square panels,
these are navety and discs,
they are used in earlier Nabataeans architecture.
So,
once again,
this very interesting and very fruitful coming together of nab a t and elements
and,
um,
Roman elements in this extraordinary tomb of the mid second century.
And then I show you on the lefthand side of the screen,
the finial that caps the thought loss,
uh,
and an a,
a fellow sitting over here at the base of the finial is very helpful to us
because he gives us a sense of human scale.
This is this Mandi small compared to the finial.
So you can imagine how small he is in relationship to the tomb as a whole.
So once again,
bitter bigger is better reign supreme,
uh,
in Jordan as it did in Rome,
where we can see that the Romans are building very large,
uh,
in the second century.
If we look at this finial here,
this decoration at the apex,
we see that they have used one of these Nabataeans capital's a again here and
that that supports a kind of fat of vase on the top with a,
with a top on it,
uh,
and that,
that you see that sort of thing in,
in Roman art.
Uh,
you see it sometimes in the second style Roman wall paintings,
probably a Greco Roman motif that has been combined with the nabbit t and
capital here.
Uh,
and you can also see from looking at this as well as a tomb as a whole,
that the architect is really treating these buildings almost more as sculpture,
then his architecture molding them in a way that a sculptor might,
uh,
and that's not so different from what we saw were Iberia's for example,
doing,
uh,
in his,
octagonal room and in the fountain at the Palace on the Palatine Hill here
again,
Borromini Francesco Borromini,
Santiko,
uh,
the upper most part of that,
just to show you again,
the kind of these are,
and by no means,
you know,
there's no exact relationship between these two at all.
And this one has different features than that.
But just to show you that it's this kind of thing that unquestionably inspires
architects like Barmini in the 17th century,
in Italy,
uh,
to create the kind of,
of,
um,
of lanterns and so on.
But they do a for the,
that they design.
Here's another interesting comparisons is a wonderful view of the day,
year in Pietra,
which shows you,
I guess best of all the way in which it is carved out of and still embedded into
the rock,
uh,
of Peatra itself.
Magnificent.
And I compare it here too to another Borromini church.
This is the famous church of San Carlo.
All a Quattro Fontana,
uh,
most,
most better known his son Carlino with a little Sun Carlo.
So on Carlino as you see here and you see what Borromini has done,
he has an undulating facade.
He's using the traditional vocabulary of architecture just like these architects
are,
these nameless architects are the columns and the tablature is and the pediments
and so on and so forth.
He's using all of those here even as a full loss,
uh,
in the second and the upper story right there.
Uh,
but he is used any is,
and he is also very taken with the whole idea of the have an actual undulating
wall as you can see also in this view.
Uh,
but he is doing the same sort of thing,
uh,
that we see architects doing here.
And I don't think there's any question that the sort of building that we see on
the right,
the day year,
uh,
was,
had impact on architects in the 17th century.
We know that some of them traveled to this part of the world.
We know that drawings were made,
that books were made,
that these were brought back and these were seen by people in Rome in the 17th
century.
And of course they had local things to see as well in Italy.
Uh,
and that they were influenced by what they saw.
The other rock cut tomb,
the other very impressive raw there,
many of them in pizza.
I'm only showing you two out of a fairly nice variety.
Uh,
but I want to show you the other most famous one,
the cause nay in um,
in uh,
Peatra also dates to the mid second century.
A D once again carved out of the living rock.
Once again,
pure facade ism.
This is nothing more than a facade.
A,
you can see,
uh,
how um,
in this case,
once again,
second,
two storied,
very,
very similar scheme to what we saw at the day or two stories with a temple front
down below and a full loss above.
It is revealed by the splitting of the triangular pediment.
As you can see.
Well,
uh,
once again,
the full loss definitely treated as a decorative motif.
Yes,
in this case it has a statue on a base,
but a statue on a base that is not a real statue on a base,
but a statue on a base that is carved onto the,
uh,
onto the stone.
So once again,
we get a sense that this is a decorative motif rather than an actual statue
standing in the thought of loss.
And the same for the items on the basis on either side,
you can see the triangular pediment very well.
You can see the way it has been split aside to reveal the thaw loss.
You can see down below a real temple front.
In this case,
one is much closer to its Roman,
uh,
prototypes in the sense that even the decorative motifs are Roman,
unlike in the day year where we saw the Nabataeans capitals and the discs.
Here we see actual,
uh,
versions of the Corinthian order use the Corinthian order used here.
This looks very much like a real temple front with an actual pediment sculptural
decoration of freeze as well.
We're beginning to see in this one,
not only the use of the traditional vocabulary of architecture,
not only the enlivening of the surface,
using that traditional vocabulary of architecture through these,
through in such a way that it creates motion projection,
recession,
projection,
recession.
Uh,
but,
but we also are seeing here in a way that we did not end the day year,
this interest in excess ornamentation.
Ornamenting every service that you possibly can,
uh,
with sculptural freezes,
with Pedimento sculpture,
with,
uh,
with statuary carved into the stone in all of the niches.
Uh,
and,
but then again,
much closer relationship to earlier Roman precedents by the temple front,
by the use of the Corinthian order.
Uh,
but this one to a very similar,
a finial at the top of the throw loss,
uh,
but using a kind of Corinthian capital with one of those vases on top vases by
the way,
that we often see in second style Roman wall painting.
Once again,
one could come up with a lot of comparisons for the cause,
nay with monuments,
with the 17th century Baroque buildings in Rome.
This may not be the best,
but it's one of my favorites and I decided to show it in this context,
but it's the Church of Santa Maria is written to the Piazza Navona Santa Maria
del a Paci designed by Pietro.
Dot.
Tortona same sort of idea,
you know the temple front down below.
Yes,
this is a different kind of temple front cause it's around temple and not one
with a pediment,
but the same general idea of having a temple front below.
And then a second story above all of this enlivened with a traditional
vocabulary of architecture columns,
columns,
pilasters a window in the niche right up there.
Very interesting.
A segmental pediment inside of triangular pediment.
Uh,
just to show you that this kind of experimentation that we see in 17th century
Baroque architecture mostly in church building,
but also in palaces,
uh,
is so clearly,
so clearly inspired,
let's say,
uh,
by the,
Baroque architecture of Roman antiquity.
Couple of more details here.
Here's a wonderful view,
uh,
from down below showing you the throw loss of the cause,
nay at Peatra,
uh,
and comparing it to once again,
some of the confections of baroque architects in Rome of the 17th century,
namely Sonde Evo,
again,
uh,
with its curved facade and,
um,
and,
and wonderful,
uh,
eight sided dome,
and some of the interior decoration also have sand ebo above
staying on the,
staying in the eastern empire.
Uh,
I want to go now to,
uh,
to ancient Asia minor to two sites on the coast,
on the western coast of what is now Turkey Ephesus and my leaders emphasis in my
leaders.
And I want to begin,
uh,
in Ephesus to show you one building there of considerable interest,
I think in terms of its relationships to Rome.
Uh,
it is the temple of Hadrian,
so called,
uh,
that dates to around one 20 to 138 D in Ephesus.
We know Hadrian visited emphasis.
Uh,
we know that those who lived there wanted to honor him by building a temple a to
him,
it's actually more a shrine than a temple.
This is not a bigger is better.
This is actually a fairly small structure,
as I said,
Morris shrine than it is a temple.
It's a kind of street side,
a temple.
You're walking along the street and then they're there.
They're all of a sudden it is.
But what's interesting about it is the fact that it makes use of the RQ weighted
lintel as you can see here,
straight and curved,
just as we saw it used at the Canopius at Hadrian's villa.
So a motif that we see in Italy,
uh,
being used also in Asia minor for a nother Hadrian Anik building.
So it's becoming associated in the minds of designers with Hadrian himself.
So traditional vocabulary of architecture,
but,
uh,
used in a,
in a different way by using the straight and RQ weighted lintel together.
This is a very good example of this interest in over ornamentation.
Every single square inch,
uh,
of,
of is used by the architects,
uh,
to decorate as you can see,
the architrave,
uh,
and also the lintel and the back.
Uh,
and the pilasters and the back.
All of them,
uh,
decorated to the point where the decoration,
almost dematerializes the architectural members.
Another detail where I think you can see that particularly well here on the
right,
this dematerialization of the architectural members through sculpture.
And you'll remember this same,
uh,
the same approach in the Severen basilica in leftist Maga.
Uh,
this is a detail of the peers that we believe were added during the time of
Caracalla.
So round two,
16,
[inaudible],
uh,
obviously much later in date,
but we see already here this interest in this sort of thing that's going to
culminate at places like Leptin.
And also just to make the point that this same use of the straight and RQ
weighted lintel that we see in Adrianic architecture turns up also in 17th
century Baroque Rome.
I show you the interior of Sun Carlino here where you can see again the strait
and RQ weighted lintels combined.
So clearly 17th century Baroque architects.
Looking back at Roman [inaudible] examples,
I want to show you briefly a gate at my elitists.
Also as you saw in ancient Asian minor,
it's the gate to the South Agora or marketplace of my leaders and a dates to
around a d two,
160.
It is no longer in my leaders.
It was moved,
uh,
some years ago as antiquities sometimes are,
from its country of origin to Germany.
It's now can be seen.
The museum in Berlin,
uh,
they also have a great model in Berlin that shows you the relationship of the
gate to the rest of the Roman city and you can see the gate way up there and
incredible showpiece for the city.
This gate,
that end that allowed one to enter into the South Agora.
I show it to you as reconstructed in the museum in Berlin.
It is quite an impressive piece.
You can see here it is that it is a gate and it shows that you can apply these
baroque facades to just about any kind of architecture.
You see that the gate has a triple opening down below three blind windows.
Uh,
on top.
It is made entirely out of stone.
It uses the traditional vocabulary of architecture,
uh,
columns and capitals.
You can see the capitols in this case are uh,
seem to be um,
composite capitals and it is very much the theater,
the theater skein I fronds idea with a series of projecting elements on top of
two columns with wings on either side.
Also projecting down below the lintels are straight,
but up above they have combined full triangular pediments in the wings with a
broken triangular pediment in the center.
And the broken triangular pediment is in the center is particularly interesting
because you can see the two sides left and right up above.
But you can also see that they've included the center of the pediment,
but in a plane that is further back,
so you get this kind of zigzag,
a motif where you begin,
the pediment begins in the front,
uh,
front zone,
and then Zig zags to the backs zone,
uh,
which,
which injects even further,
even a greater motion into the overall scheme.
Once again,
we see the projection,
that recession projection recession,
all using the traditional vocabulary of architecture.
It's interesting to compare this to a much earlier gate in Greece.
I show you the proper Aleya,
the gateway to the Athenian Acropolis Fifth Century BC where you can see it's
all function.
They've used the doric order here,
uh,
and the columns support the roof above try glyphs and Mehta piece.
The whole idea.
I mean,
it's very beautiful.
Uh,
but the whole idea is to use these columns functionally very different in this
gate,
uh,
in my latest in the second century,
a d out where you can see that the columns are no longer used for structural
purposes,
but mainly to decorate and to enliven and to add motion to the structure.
In a way that is entirely out of keeping with these important Greek precedents.
Here you see a detail,
uh,
some tourists,
looking at the,
uh,
at this and other things in the museum in Berlin,
which gives you,
again,
a sense of the colossal scale of this structure.
Here you can see also very well,
uh,
the composite capitals as well as once again,
this interest in,
uh,
an almost overly decorative surface that is so characteristic of baroque
architecture.
A number of you embarked on the library of Calcis as your paper topics,
so I'm sure you know everything there is to know about that,
but I want to show it to you quickly in the context of this lecture because it's
an important monument for all of you to be aware of.
Less.
Do think that it has always looked the way it looks.
Now,
I show you a view that was taken well by now 25 years ago or so,
uh,
before the building was redirected a,
which it has been since that the building,
this is,
this is what the library of Kelsey's looked like a 25 or so years ago.
Uh,
and,
but fortunately,
even though everything had fallen down,
it was all there.
As you can see,
there were fragments strewn everywhere,
hundreds and hundreds of fragments strewn around the site and enough fragments
so that the,
basically the building was there and what they eventually decided to do was use
those fragments to redirect it,
which took a number of years and the results have been truly spectacular.
I show you a view,
uh,
of emphasis as it looks today,
looking back toward the rear erected library of Kelsey's and then a better view
here where you can see what all of those pieces,
the giant jigsaw puzzle that all of those pieces ultimately made a,
you can see here this incredible facade of the,
uh,
of the library of Kelsey's in emphasis.
And you can see the scheme is the same as I just showed you in the South Agora
market gate at my lead us in this case to tears.
Uh,
the bottom tiers,
very similar to what we saw there.
Just two columns supporting a straight A and tablature above.
And then in the second story,
the addition of more decorative elements with segmental to segmental pediments
flanking a rectangular one in the center with separate individual columns at
either end,
like we saw on the day year,
uh,
with supporting,
projecting and tablature,
uh,
once again,
using the traditional vocabulary of architecture to create motion across the
service projection,
recession,
projection,
recession.
Uh,
and,
but here,
one very interesting feature is that if you look at the second story and the
placement of those second story on top of those below,
you can see that the ones at the top are not directly above the ones at the
bottom as we saw on the market gates gate.
But they straddle the space below,
which is very interesting.
So instead of having the two co two columns with a pediment above right above
this,
you can see the columns with the pediment above or right above this space.
So they're straddling the spaces,
which if you look at it for a while,
you'll see,
adds an additional sense of motion,
uh,
to the surface of this structure.
I think you can also see from this general view,
uh,
the,
the interest in ornamentation,
you can see that perhaps much better here in these details.
Here's a detail of one of the niches.
Some of the statues are still preserved with the names of the figures.
In a Greek down below,
you can see the way in which they have essentially dematerialize the peers by
decorating them.
So extensively.
And this wonderful view up where you can see the very gated marble that is used
here.
You can see the coffered ceiling,
you can see the deep cut undercutting of the capitals and the tablets are and
how overly ornamental it actually is.
Uh,
and uh,
you can also see that in the upper most part,
actually what they've created here in this particular building is something that
looks very much,
I think like the architectural cages at the,
at the upper tier of the fourth style.
And I remind you of a detail of one of those from that fragment from Herculaneum
that shows the same sort of a coffered ceiling and uh,
elements as well as the split a triangular pediment,
uh,
that we see also in built architecture in the second century.
Aidy in Ephesus.
Uh,
the inside of the structure looked like this.
This is from Ward Perkins showing you one main niche,
a couple of other tiers with columns,
much simpler inside as you can see,
uh,
the,
the niches where you had shelves and this is where the scrolls were kept in the
library.
Uh,
and here,
uh,
a niche that beneath which was a place for the last resting place of Kelsey's.
I mentioned this to you when we talked about the paper topics that kills wanted.
He built this library as a benefaction to his city,
uh,
to benefit the citizenry obviously of the city as well as seven building to put
his name on.
But he liked it so much and it meant so much to him that he decided to make it
his own too.
He was buried in his library.
The neath,
that Central Niche,
uh,
you see in plan here,
the location of that central niche.
Uh,
so,
so as he could be,
he could be in the midst of this extraordinary building that he built in
perpetuity.
A,
another show piece done in the same row.
Ancient Roman Baroque style [inaudible] is the one that you see here in a
restored view from the word Perkins Textbook.
It dates to the early second century,
a D it's a Nymph Fam or a fountain located at and my leaders in Turkey,
uh,
we see it here.
And,
uh,
it,
it was also an extraordinary structure.
Uh,
it was much more ostentatious than it needed to be.
It could get the job done with a lot less.
Uh,
its purpose was to serve as a fountain.
You've got the base and down below you could do this with a single story,
certainly.
Uh,
but they built up three stories in this particular place.
They've been as ostentatious as they possibly can.
They spent as much money as they possibly can.
Uh,
because I think it was a form of oneupsmanship from one city to the next,
you know,
I have a better fountain then you've got,
or I've got a more ornate fountain.
Then you've got a was the whole idea our city is doing particularly well.
Uh,
because you can see what,
uh,
what,
what prosperity has wrought by this amazing fountain that we've been able to
build for the benefaction of the people of the city,
of my leaders.
Uh,
and you can see that this game is the same.
It looks back certainly to the theatrical architecture to the second style
painting and fourth style painting that we've talked about here.
Uh,
the same general idea with the first story,
a series of double columns with a straight in tablature is above in the second
story,
the addition of pediments in this case triangular pediments combined with these
interesting scroll motifs over some of the pairs of columns.
And then in the upper most a story triangular pediments once again a niches
behind them and between them with statuary as you can also see.
And then pilasters decorative pilasters on the wall.
This one also has wings,
but you can see that the wings are even more elaborate than the wings we've seen
in any of the other structures.
Uh,
and they in fact have pediments that face in toward the central part of the
structure and toward the fountain.
Proper Perkins has added a few figures here that give you a sense once again of
the enormity of the scale of this,
uh,
amazing,
fountain in the city of my leaders.
I mentioned that although I was going to concentrate today on Baroque
architecture and the eastern part of the empire,
I would not,
I would show you at least an at one example from the west and I show that to you
here.
Uh,
it takes us back to North Africa to a place called sub Rotha,
which is located in between Tim Gad and leftist Mon that we looked at last time.
Here's the side of sub Rotha and you can see that it too is located on the sea.
And extraordinary theater was built there.
And it's another example of the way in which these baroque facades could be used
for a whole host of buildings.
It could be used for,
uh,
for theaters and for temples and for fountains and for libraries,
and uh,
so on and so forth.
And,
but theater,
theater,
architecture,
it was particularly appropriate for,
because we've seen from the very beginning of Rome that these kinds of ornate a
columnar,
uh,
schemes were used quite frequently in theatrical architecture.
We are looking at the exterior of the theater at Sobrato.
What you can see from your monument list dates to around 200.
Uh,
it has been redirected,
much of it had fallen down,
but once again,
there was quite a bit of this stone was there.
And so they redirected the facade.
You can see that it like pretty much everything we've looked at today has,
was made out of local stone.
Uh,
and you can also see two tears and you can see that although it's made out of
local stone,
it is very similar to the sort of thing we saw much earlier in Rome itself.
Think of the theater of Marcellus.
Think of the Coliseum,
the scheme of arches with uh,
with uh,
pilasters or columns in between them engaged into the wall.
As you can see,
so well here,
if you look at the view on the left,
you will see however,
the stage building of the theater at sub Brotha is particularly well preserved.
And I want to show you two views too,
spectacular views.
This one in particular,
uh,
which shows you what this structure looked like in antiquity and what it looks
like now.
And it is another one of these extraordinary baroque facades.
Again.
So typical for theatrical architecture.
We see the three great niches as we often do.
Think of the plan of the Augustan theater at a leftist Magnar for example,
three great niches.
These columnar elements on either side,
in three stories,
no straddling here,
just they are just on top one another as you can see,
well,
but a series of four instead of the usual two.
But then within the niches,
they've also created a,
these elements in this case with two columns,
that project,
they're inside the niche.
They're contained inside the niche,
but they project in front of the niche,
adding even more enlivenment meant to the structure look down below also.
And we don't,
we rarely have the bottom of the stage preserve,
but we have it preserved here in preserved extremely well.
Uh,
the bottom of the stage has been scalped.
It has projecting elements with columns and the whole thing is decorated with
sculpture.
So many figures that those figures even seem to almost d materialize the stone a
crowd if you're not,
not just a few figures that you can read very well,
but a whole host of crowds of figures that show,
again,
this interest in over decoration in these baroque building sees another view.
Uh,
not quite as clear,
but I think a very good one that also gives you a very good sense not only of
the stage decoration but at the scale of this structure because we've got a few
tourists standing here would show you that once again,
a bigger is better.
Uh,
is clearly the rallying call of the day.
Here's a detail of some of that decoration,
gods and goddesses and the like.
We see the three graces here for example,
but you can see the way they are crowded in a,
to give one a sense of um,
of uh,
a kind of excess ornamentation,
which was obviously very popular during this period.
The last set of buildings that I want to show you are in many respects the most
interesting of all.
And this is a group of buildings that are part of a complex in what is now
Lebanon.
Uh,
the city of ball back the so called sanctuary of Jupiter,
Helio Paula Polatis at Baalbek,
which was constructed over a 200 year period from the mid first century,
had to the mid third century,
a d,
uh,
the location of Baalbek is right over here,
as I said,
in modern Lebanon.
And the remains are incredible.
The remains are incredible.
Every so often there's often fighting.
This is in the Bekaa valley,
so there's often fighting that breaks out in this particular part of the world.
And one worries about these monuments.
But so far they seem to have withstood some of the,
of the,
um,
the difficulties that,
that,
that area has experienced in recent years.
And you see some of them here in the nicely silhouetted against the landscape,
but this gives you a better idea of what the complex looked like in antiquity.
And I show it to you here again,
it was built over a series of years,
but let's just talk about it as a whole and then I'll break down the chronology
for you.
It had a grand entrance way with a single staircase facade orientation,
uh,
with a RQ and RQ weighted lintel here contained within a pediment.
Then interestingly enough,
you went from that entrance way into a hexagonal court,
uh,
open to the sky from the hexagonal court into this great open rectangular space
surrounded by columns,
a very large altar right here to Jupiter because the main temple in this complex
was the temple to Jupiter.
And you see it also in the restored view at the back.
So the Alternate Jupiter,
the Temple of Jupiter.
If you look at the temple to Jupiter,
you will see it's very similar to the temples that we've been looking at out of
the course of the semester.
Very tall podium,
single staircase facade orientation,
uh,
deep porch,
freestanding columns in that porch and the like.
And you can also see that there is a nother temple right outside the walls of
this one.
This is so called Temple of Bacchus,
which is one of the three that was part of this complex.
It also seems to have had its own little courtyard and then down here out of the
picture,
a round temple to Venus that we're also going to look at.
This is a restored view of the same showing you the infant's way,
the hexagonal court,
the large temple to Jupiter,
the smaller temple to Baucus and the forecourt that it to would have had as well
as this much less elaborate entrance way into the temple of Baucus.
This is perhaps the most spectacular view I've shown you all semester of
anything.
I mean,
this is really an awesome photograph,
I think taken from the air.
Needless to say,
I can't like credit to this and it was taken from the air.
Uh,
but you see it here and it is amazing,
uh,
amazing photograph that really gives you a better sense than anything else might
have the current remains where you can see the end France gate.
Uh,
you can see that the,
the staircases is a shadow of what it once was.
It was one much wider.
You can see the hexagonal court from above.
You can see the open rectangular space.
You can see the bear remains of the altar.
And you can see the temple of Jupiter,
which has its podium,
not much of it staircase and only six columns still surviving.
But the temple,
a Baucus outside the walls,
much better preserved and gives us a very good sense of these temples as a
whole.
Uh,
a plan over here showing the same,
the entrance court,
the hexagonal and France way,
the open rectangular space at a,
the temple of Jupiter,
be the temple of Baucus and here,
uh,
and engraving showing the entrance way.
With this,
uh,
with this RQ weighted lintel just as we saw a popular in the Adriatic period and
the pediment now the chronology is that the temple of Jupiter was built first in
the mid first century ID.
That's way back.
That's like the time of Claudius and Nero mid first century had,
uh,
then,
in the second century there were um,
uh,
other additions and it was in the third century that the provolone and the
hexagonal chord,
the second century actually was the open rectangular space was added in the
second century.
And then in the third century they added the hexagonal court and the entrance
way.
So moving from the back toward the front,
these are the six columns that are preserved of the temple of Jupiter at
Baalbek.
Uh,
they are incredibly,
the whole structure is incredibly large and this is the,
this is the biggest building we've seen thus far.
Uh,
we know there were 10 columns in the front,
19 on the sides there again,
made out of honey colored local limestone.
I think as you can see so well in both of these views.
In this case,
the podium was 44 feet tall,
44 feet tall,
the podium at the temple of the temple of the DDI.
We at the forum at leptos magnet was 19 feet tall and we thought that was big.
This is 44 feet tall and the columns were 65 feet tall.
Uh,
and remember those columns that sell a stole from grease 55 feet tall for the
temple of Jupiter Omc.
These are 10,
you know,
are much taller than that.
So it gives you some sense of the incredible scale of this structure.
Here's the plan of the temple of Baucus,
the second temple that I want to show you,
that dates to the mid second century,
a d a,
we see it here.
You can get a very good sense of its structure and you can see the way in which
it combines.
Typical Roman with a Greek features,
single staircase facade orientation,
deep porch,
freestanding columns in the porch,
single cell.
Ah,
but it has a peripheral colonnade,
uh,
as one finds in,
in Greek architecture.
But it doesn't have a peripheral staircases.
I'll show you in a moment.
It has rather a high podium here you see it.
Uh,
it is very well preserved.
You can see the columns in circling the whole building but you can see there is
no staircase circling the whole building but a very high podium.
A few people here for scale.
This is a big building and this building is much smaller than the temple of
Jupiter.
These buildings are so bail big that someone,
I guess tongue in cheek wrote an article at one point suggesting that this could
not have been built by human beings,
Romans or otherwise,
uh,
and was definitely built by Martians who came down in a spaceship and build it
and then left but left us with something quite extraordinary if that was indeed
the case.
Once again,
overly decorative,
overly decorative.
If you look at,
we could look at a whole host of details would,
if you look at them,
you will see extraordinary things were looking up in one of the bolts and you
can see how it's been nearly pretty much eaten away by this excessive
decoration.
The same here with this wonderful,
uh,
Medusa head in the center.
No,
no,
no inch is left,
uh,
undecorated by these architects.
This is one of the best preserved interiors of a Roman temple that we have the
temple of Bacchus.
We are looking through the doorway.
If you look at the jams of the doorway,
you will see,
uh,
how,
how decorated they are.
And again,
again,
the way in which they have been deemed materialized through that ornamentation
looking into,
uh,
the,
the interior.
And I can show you a better view here.
Uh,
you get a very good sense of what the structure looked like in antiquity,
that truly colossal Corinthian columns in this particular case,
the niches on two stories with RQ weighted pediments and with triangular
pediments up above,
uh,
the extraordinary scale of this highly decorative interior.
And I can show you a restored view of what we think this looked like in
antiquity.
At first glance,
it doesn't look so different from,
you know,
this sort of Basilica Olivia idea in Rome,
uh,
with the,
with the flat ceiling,
the coffered ceiling,
the giant columns and so on.
But of course,
it has no isles since it's,
I mean,
it has,
it does.
I'm sorry.
It does have aisles here.
Uh,
but you can see the occupations.
You can see the pediments.
Uh,
with the sculpture inside,
you can see the Corinthian capitals,
and you can see,
uh,
no clear story here,
but you can see a very interesting feature at the,
uh,
at the end,
the focus of everyone who came into this temple was the so called Adi
[inaudible],
Adi Tom,
which is a kind of a shrine in which the cult statue of Baucus would have been
presented.
You can see it well here,
uh,
and you can see the use of the broken triangular pediment,
but one that is very similar to that market gate in that the central element
with its triangle is still preserved but preserved in a plane that is further
back.
So that kind of Zigzag motion,
uh,
that we see here,
the great arc of vault underneath the paired columns on either side,
the shrine in the center of very elaborate Motif done in the style that we have
described as baroque.
Uh,
for this incredible structure I want to end today by showing you the,
uh,
my favorite of all the buildings that I've shown you today because it's so
eccentric.
And that is the temple of Venus at Baalbek.
It's the small temple that lies outside the complex to the left of the complex
and the front.
Uh,
and it's the latest of the three temples,
uh,
probably dates to early to mid third century a d and also by far the smallest.
It's very small in relationship to the others.
It is also a round temple unlike them,
which are the traditional rectangular temples around temple.
But around temple with a difference.
If we look at the plan,
we will see it as a single staircase of facade orientation,
deep porch,
freestanding columns in that porch.
It also is peripheral.
It has columns that go all the way around.
Uh,
it is around structure with a round seller.
but you can see in plan that the architect has scallop,
uh,
the outside of the structure in a very interesting way.
Uh,
and you can see that also in these restored views over here that scalloping both
on the base and also in the area of the tablet.
You're above the columns.
You can also see that the architect has decades place niches on the outside of
the,
of the structure,
uh,
with,
with statues in them,
which is another example of this desire to decorate every surface that one
possibly could.
There's a great deal of controversy as to what the porch actually looked like
and whether the porch had what we see here,
which is an RQ weighted lintel inside a,
a triangular pediment.
That's possible.
It may not have had that.
We're not absolutely sure,
but at the very least we have this combination of what seems like a relatively
traditional porch with an innovative body.
It is in a sense,
a small version and a very eccentric version of the Pantheon in Rome with that
traditional porch and revolutionary body.
But this is not made out of concrete.
It is made entirely out of local stone.
Uh,
and again,
it has these wonderful features like the scallops base,
and I show you a detail is very well preserved today as are the other buildings,
or at least the temple of Baal office at Baalbek.
Uh,
we see it here.
You can see it's stone construction,
unfortunately black and white,
but you can get a sense it's the same honey colored stone is the others.
You can see the way it looks here.
You can see the scallop base,
the Scallop,
the wonderful scallop and tablature.
And when did they,
over the overly decorative nature of that in tablets or above,
in this case,
Corinthian capitals.
As you can see some traditional motifs like this hanging garlands,
the niches here with the statuary making the whole into a kind of decorative
motif.
Even the outside of the seller becomes decorative.
But look very carefully and you will see,
uh,
that the bases of the columns are five sided to make them work better with the
scallop wall.
This is the second time we've seen basis like this.
We saw them in the tomb of [inaudible] in Rome,
a base that had multiple more sides than was usual.
We see that here,
and it's a testimony again to the eccentricity of this particular designer.
Uh,
but also to the sort of anything goes approach that we see in so much of this
Roman Baroque architecture.
And I just in closing the last two images that I'd like to show you are a detail
of the temple of Venus at ball back with a temple with a detail of a bar meany,
uh,
structure.
Uh,
this one is the bar meeting structure.
This one is the temple of Venus.
But I think when you look at views like this,
you can see the closest.
So you can see what I mean by defining these as Baroque buildings already in
Roman antiquity.
But you can see the extraordinary impact that these amazing Roman creations had
on the minds and on the Aurora of great architects like Bernini and Borromini in
the 17th century in Italy.
Thank you very much.